two students need to study to survive in
the age of artificial intelligence it's
not a question of survival you are about
to enter I think like the greatest
golden age of human possibility
technological development economic
growth it's like I think it's going to
be quite fantastic
um to thrive in that world I think the
skills that matter are
deep familiarity with the tools and
staying abreast of changes and just
working with them very closely to
develop a great intuition for where
things are going and how to make use of
it resilience a very like ability to
learn new things fast and adapt to them
and sort of evolve yourself with
technology